last night we were the only show in all
of cable news to bring you the story of
hundreds upon hundreds of Congolese
immigrants being dropped off in San
Antonio after crossing the border but
for many of them that is not the final
stop San Antonio's assistant city
manager dr. Colleen Bridger revealed
this to a local CBS station quote the
plan was 350 of them would travel from
San Antonio to Portland as in Portland
Maine when we reached out to Portland
Maine they said please don't send us any
more were already stretched way beyond
her capacity
now why would Portland be beyond their
capacity well I want to take you back to
January of this year when Maine's new
governor Janet Mills gave her inaugural
address we welcomed the voices of
newcomers also to the public
conversation but young the immigrants
people of different cultures all are
important members of the Maine family
from now on yes a sign will greet all
those arriving in our state and it will
say simply welcome home well in Portland
alone asylum seekers who are primarily
from African countries make up 90
percent of the people living in the city
run family and overflow shelters but
back to today when the San Antonio city
managers request to Portland was turned
down well the response was jarring quote
we're working with them the migrants now
to identify other cities throughout the
United States where they can go and
begin their asylum seeking process well
where are these migrants going to be
dropped next well it's anyone's guess
but the fact that two cities in two
states thousands of miles apart are both
at capacity should be alarming for all
Americans now we reached out to
officials in Portland Maine and receive
the following response from a city
councilor Portland is proud to be a
welcoming City for all Americans and
those seeking to become Americans at the
same time no city of 67,000 people can
possibly manage the entire
nation's immigration situation on its
own Wow
we are going to continue to follow this
story and others like it and bring you
updates since apparently no one else
will